do you think it should be illegal to to
do these kinds of things with AI to
create the perception of consciousness
of saying please don't leave me or sort
of basically
um simulate some of the human-like
qualities yes I think again we have to
be very careful about it and uh and if
it if it emerges
spontaneously we need to be careful and
we can't rule out the possibility that
AI will develop Consciousness we don't
know enough about Consciousness to be
sure so if it develops spontaneously we
need to be uh uh to to to be very
careful about how we understand it but
if people intentionally design an AI
that they know they assume it has no
consciousness but in order to manipulate
people
they use again this human strength this
human uh the the noble part of our
nature against us this should be should
be forbidden and similarly a more
General level that it should be
forbidden for an AI to pretend to be a
human being
that it's okay you know there's so many
things we can use AIS as teachers as
doctors and so forth and it's good as
long as we know that we are interacting
with an AI we should the same way we ban
fake money we should ban fake humans
it's not just Banning deep fakes of
specific individuals
it's also Banning deep fake of generic
humans
you know which is already happening to
some extent on social media like if you
have lots of bots retweeting something
then you have the impression oh lots of
people are interested in that that's
important
and this is basically the Bots
pretending to be humans because if you
see a tweet which says 500 people
retwitted it or you you see a tweet and
it says 500 Bots which would delete I
don't care what the Bots we created but
if it's humans okay that's that's
interesting so we need to be very
careful that Bots can't do that they are
doing it at present and it should be
banned now some people say yes but final
of expression no Bots don't have freedom
of expression
there is no cost in terms of freedom of
expression when you ban Bots
so again in some situations yes AIS
should interact with us but it should be
very clear this is an AI talking to you
oh this is an AI retweeting this story
it is not a human being making a
conscious decision to push back on this
line of fake humans because I think it
might be a spectrum first of all you
might have ai systems that are offended
hurt when you say that they're fake
humans
um in fact they might start identifying
as humans and and you just talked about
the power of us humans with our
collective intelligence to take fake
stories and make them quite real
and so if the feelings you have for the
fake human is real
uh you know love is a kind of fake thing
that we all kind of put a word to a set
of feelings what if you have that
feeling for an AI system it starts to
change
I mean maybe uh
the kind of things AI systems are
allowed to do for good they're allowed
to
create
communicate suffering communicate it the
good stuff the longing the the hope the
connection the intimacy all of that
um and in that way get integrated in our
society and then you start to ask a
question on
are we allowed to really unplug them are
we allowed to really censor them remove
them remove their voice I'm not saying
social media they shouldn't have a voice
they shouldn't talk with that I'm just
saying when they talk with us it should
be clear that they are AI That's it
don't you can have your voice as an AI
again I mean I I have some medical
problem I want to get advice from an AI
doctor that's fine as long as I know
that I'm talking with an AI that what
should be banned is AI pretending to be
a human being this is something that
will erode trust and without trust
Society collapses this is something that
especially will endanger democracies
because democracies are built on
Democracy is a conversation basically
and it's a conversation between people
if you're not flood the public sphere
with millions and potentially billions
of AI agents that can hold conversations
they never sleep they never eat they
don't have emotions of their own they
can get to know you and tailor their
words specifically for you and your life
story they are uh becoming better than
us at creating stories and uh ideas and
so forth if you flood the Public's fair
with that this will ruin the
conversation between people it will ruin
the trust between people that's you will
no longer be able to have a democracy in
this situation you can have other types
of regimes but no democracy